hello gays once we could hang at a free
Tuesday at 2 p.m. Pacific right here Oh
guess what cop how you doing a tow folks
I'm a host I need to are joined by
Michael my Hardy hey I'm Tyson Roose
hello you handsome gentleman's having
representin bro yeah team bro yeah so
who better to talk about buddy fantasy
role-playing games then then team bro
2015 has been a great year for video
games yes we have a bunch of stuff to
talk about
on today's show that let alone Metal
Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain which
we've all been playing and but one of
the games we were playing earlier this
year a lot of and I want like a sitrep
from both of you it was the Witcher 3
Wild Hunt which we've today seen the
first trailer for their their new
expansion pack yeah a little teaser
trailer yeah how far you in Walden if
you completed Waldo oh yeah I finished
it you finished it I sex with everyone
yes even that one all of them yeah Mike
what about you yeah yeah but I've not
even I've done this I'm like a hundred
and thirty hours into my game I played a
lot hundred twenty yeah yeah but I'm
like I'm like you know apparently
there's no spoilers to tyranny there's a
part where you think it's going to end
yes so I even haven't completed that yet
130 hours yeah it's so really good
that's that part where I'm like oh the
game must be ending right here it's over
and then all of a sudden you're like oh
wait no and then more there's like 20
more hours I can play at that game
what's I happened to see you play 120
hours is 120 but I did a lot of random
[ __ ] yeah well having sex yeah NPCs
apparently yeah yeah I mean that was
part of my goal but they they it kind of
screws your over at the in there because
then no one loves you at the end again
no spoiler by the way sorry it's just
like life it is you go around how have
you seen have you seen that ending no
haven't no spoilers I want spoiling what
doesn't say [ __ ] all I know is be a good
guy and pick one person I've already
[ __ ] that up I think Mike what about
you how about how long have you played
yeah something like you know 110 120
range I beat I beat it I kind of played
through it like just two weeks
straightens four you're doing between
like right before I moved out to the
west coast and I was kind of you know
trying to do all this icon that I try to
do all the Witcher contracts yeah those
bees which
we might some of my favorite parts but
yeah once I finish the main story you
know there's that like that one climax
and you think that's the end but it
keeps on truckin so many climax so I've
kind of yes tie had many climaxes as
well it sounds like any so it sounds
like a game that it was a game when I
was playing it that I realized I had the
same problem I would open more games I'd
the same thing with Fallout New Vegas
which I've only completed after hundreds
of hours
I only competed like three months ago
because I just I never liked completing
games because I'm worried that I won't
like I'm gonna miss out on certain
quests and stuff like that so I like
paced myself on The Witcher 3 and now
Metal Gear Solid's out like 5% of that
game complete after like 20 hours or
something November and we just found out
about hearts of stone which is the new
furniture like first paid expansion
first real expansion yeah for the rich
earthy world home which is gonna have
another 10 plus hours at worth of gaming
content this could you forgive me it's a
good year it's out in October so we've a
little bit of time for Metal Gear Solid
do you think you're gonna have any times
actually get into the expansion yeah it
depends how much I invest into Metal
Gear right now I I mean you know me I
actually don't like Metal Gear games
yeah but I love phantom pain like I
actually love this one it reminds me a
lot of it kind of combines a lot of
those like role-playing elements of like
destiny and then with like the open
world of witcher but it's all modern or
more modern it's like you know set in
the 80s but whatever like it's awesome
the gameplay is amazing so I don't see
myself quitting that anytime soon I'm
like you by the way I'm like I mean I'm
3% complete I played the game for like
10 hours so yeah and it's hard to like
parallel play these types of games yeah
it's like jump from one open-world game
yeah yeah and I mean and and if you kind
of like factor in that like you know you
have to how much free time you have you
know like are you married you have kids
yeah I mean like all that stuff right
like and I don't yeah yeah but I mean
you know there you go
you'll have more time than most people
then are some people yeah but like how
do you factor in like how do you now
make time for Fallout and then Metal
Gear and then some kind of expansion
that comes out you know in October right
yeah October 13th so I'm gonna try to
sell you on it in justice it's ten hours
though right that's it that's what they
said yeah ten hours at least
yeah a game played every what I was
flipping round up on that door right or
they estimate up like they say over a
hundred hours a game I thought
when they said about The Witcher through
Walt on first they said 200 hours and
that's like that's you could there's
probably over 200 hours now but you
really have to dig deep
yeah the good times just have sex with
really every every Biggs yet even have
to go that really won that one naughty
place where like they all the girls were
masked yeah yeah standards no standard
it's like the poor man's whorehouse it's
actually a rich man's was not any cheap
so yeah speaking to the host on is
Michael Hardy what do you think of how
do you think you have fines the play The
Witcher 3 well hem when it comes out
sorry I would like to but realistically
I probably won't get to it until early
next year because like you said fallout
4 in Metal Gear Solid 5 these are games
that inherently require a huge time
commitment and you know there's they're
very different things fallout 4 being
more of a sandbox and then your solid
being this emergent gameplay in base
kind of open world but then there's the
halo comes out like oh yeah Tomb Raider
right after yeah Tomb Raider same day as
fallout halos two weeks before that I'm
there's a lot and then like you know
early December there's just cause and
then I'll be playable six C's and stuff
I don't think anyone's like not enough
of us have gotten around to playing much
Mad Max either no because just found in
pain stay think about Game of the Year
now like think of many games you have to
play now yeah like it even have some
sort of valid opinion on what Game of
the Year is to devote all your time now
to like Metal Gear to fall out the -
mater - halo - Just Cause 3 man even
destiny we think - like all the sounds
coming out soon for that alright well
let me try and sell you on us just in
case ten hours of gameplay a crew of
such as including such stuff as a crew
of breaking artists spending a nice
partying with a ghost just its smarting
the most bizarre creature Geralt has
ever faced
and there's also ruin worlds which are
new mechanism and combat I believe now
they got into detail of what that
exactly is which there were almost of
the rune words yeah no yeah words sigh
room where it's no I feel like it's some
sort of like like specking in one type
of feeling or another or perhaps against
like specific enemies okay no they
haven't they haven't gotten to do that
yeah and they're designed for level 30
plus characters so kind of end game II
folks mostly taking place were in no
man's land on oxen first there's a new
lady in it as well
priority shamans from the first game yep
who may be able to you know you can also
they said unique romance in there that's
me what I picked out of it how unique
romance do you want your new garments
though like okay I'm raagh
sure I'm open frog pig it's 2015 Danny
what was that big thing that came with
the cows the big cow Beast
oh the I forgot what his name was an
ATAR no it was good guess though Mike
McConnell what was it was like some
beast State because people were killing
cows and selling their hides like some
like exploit in the game yeah and then
like the bovine justice warrior came out
and started screwing you up oh it was
cool I don't know I mean I'm calling you
now
yeah maybe God does yeah also okay my
favorite thing about this actually which
may make me double down for the hard
copy of this is that there's a limited
edition hard copy of this expansion
coming out that get the includes two
pairs of deck card a Gwent cards yeah
two decks of Gwent which is important
other things why are they giving you two
I was like oh yeah if you have fun you
could play with somebody because you're
the one person and it comes up rules on
how to play it like that's the most
important part I also like the idea
maybe I prefer the idea they only give
you one Gwen's deck and then you'd have
to like search the real world and find
somebody to play grant with they're
trying to expand on your social skills
exactly how dedicated you are you to
Quint yeah you must find out glint
players it's another quest we can delete
tender now though yes are you finally
finally
so it's interesting because this is one
of two expansions that we know about
that's coming out for Wild Hunt and this
one's kind of on the smaller scale like
ten hours it's it's nothing to you know
sort of is it's it's a decent amount of
gameplay but they're bringing another
one we're just going to have a whole new
world sedate you one 2016 okay
I think that's one and $25 get you both
right yes and they haven't even
announced what individual prices would
be I know I don't think there is a
question yet got it see that's the thing
like the new world aspect of it is kind
of leading me to just almost plan on
playing this next expansion
early next year yep being such a big
game and like you'd want to just kind of
absorb yourself in that game if you like
that'd be the perfect lead-in to the
next huge one I'm curious you guys when
there is like a lull like a doldrum
period where there's not a lot of games
coming out
you guys go back to like constantly man
I saw this year between I sort of I
think Witcher was launched at a perfect
time this year but yeah going into that
sort of summer Lal yeah and a lot of
people had a bunch of time I think
phantom pain if it was released any
later this year would be a little bit of
not trouble but it would be difficult to
squeeze in but the game that I went back
and played and this summer was actually
for a 3 and new Vegas yeah because I was
looking forward to fallout 4 and I know
there was like aspects of those
open-world games that I hadn't really um
in the case of New Vegas haven't played
yet yeah it's funny 3 I wanted to try it
playing in a different type of way and
those games are kind of good for a
petition that way and yeah is there
anything you've gone back to always been
pretty stacked actually since cute it
stitch I think it will be The Witcher at
this point I think that all all power
through Metal Gear you know play that
for a long time because I'm really
enjoying it and then I'll definitely try
out fallout Tomb Raider and Just Cause 3
but yeah I mean there there's always
like I go I go back to sip 5 all the
time there's nothing going on you know
and it's it's a game I was playing after
The Witcher and in-between Metal Gear
you know and so I could see myself going
back like Mike said going back to like
you know next yearly next year when
maybe not of tons coming out maybe right
before well I guess that depends a woman
chart and chart was what February now
god yes so I mean one next year yeah so
I
I probably would go back to at least
this first expansion early next year
you know maybe right after the holidays
like when CES is going on there's
nothing coming down that Jon real oh I
think I'm gonna the same thing as well
yeah oddly enough or all kind of play it
just perfectly because let's be honest
actually the game there's we're probably
all playing in our spare time I know any
time I've got five minutes to an hour me
and my girl boo table rocket League so
yeah perfect just short bursts game yeah
you know long yeah you can you can just
play for like two hours yeah good and
then I mean and I mean with Metal Gear I
can't it so that you you have to
dedicate time to that yeah like you can
get lost in that game for multiple hours
so I mean yeah I don't I I think it's
great that CD Projekt is doing this I
think that they have they're obviously
you know within good favor of the
audience you know like they've done a
great job with their DLC the last you
know you know a couple months all the
freestyle free stuff and then for 25
bucks you get two expansions now which
is a great deal and that second one
supposed to be really meaty so
I mean I I mean I saw what six million
copies of the game thing they just
announced that so I definitely see a lot
people picking us stuff up it just may
not be until early January
yeah probably limited edition coming as
well yeah both yeah for all you folks
who were looking to check out which of
three October 13 does win hearts of
stone is coming out so let us know in
the comments whether you're gonna pick
that up yourselves and let us know if
you're still playing the witcher 3 or if
like these guys you've actually managed
to complete it and are just chomping it
on-site christ let us know in the chat
or in the comments below
[Music]